التجسس صينيه وهو الذي شغل الولايات
المتحده والعالم سقط بصاروخ واحد وبامر
رئاسي بعد ان تجول لايام في الاجواء
الامريكيه هذا المنطاد بدا مساره فوق جزر
الاسكا توما اتجه نحو كندا ليحلق بعيدا
ويدخل المجال الجوي الامريكي فوق ولايه
مونتانا في الحادي والثلاثين من يناير
الاسبوع الماضي المنطاد عاده هو عباره عن
سفينه هوائيه تملا بغاز الهيدروجين او
الهيليوم يمكن ان يرتفع في الجو دون دفع
او دون جهاز دفع يحمل باسفله جهاز تجسس او
غيره حسب طبيعه هذه المهمه التي يقوم بها
هذا المنطاد اما المنطاد الصيني الذي تم
رصده في الاجواء الامريكيه فيصعب اسقاطه
من مض الطائرات لان معظم انظمه الاسلحه
المضاده للطائرات الامريكيه لم تكن مصممه
للقضاء على الاهداف المرتفعه ولاجل ذلك
لجات واشنطن لاسقاط هذا
او الاسقاط هذا المنطاد بالطائره طائره
مقاتله من طراز اف 22 اطلقت عليه صاروخا
واحدا من نوع ام
9 اكس هذا الصاروخ هو صاروخ جوجو قصير
المدى كمان نشاهد
تصل كلفته الى 400 الف دولار دخل الخدمه
في البحريه الامريكيه عام
1956 واستخدمته القوات الجويه عام
1964 الجيش الامريكي
يعمل حاليا على استعاده حموله هذا المنطاد
الذي اسقطته على بعد سته اميال بحريه
قباله سواحل الولايات المتحده وعلى عمق 47
قدما وهو ما يسهل من عمليه جمع عبر غواصين
ومركبه غير ماهوله لانتشال جسم هذا
البالون ورفعه الى السطح الى سفينه
الانتشار بهدف التحقيق فيماهيه مهمه
المنطاد الصيني
والجزم وفق هذا وفق شبكه سي ان ان عن
طبيعه هذا المنطاد
[موسيقى]